[Music]
speaking of throat nancy pelosi yeah
throatis yeah
[Laughter]
nancy reagan you mean
no it's nancy pelosi
okay let's start a rumor apparently
nancy reagan yeah throw goat and it all
started cause uh
i don't know if she's actually been
shapiro's sister that's what she's
referred to as
she tweets this is madonna at 63 this is
nancy reagan at 64. trashy living versus
classic living wait it started because
of this yeah there's no way and then so
there's an image of madonna you know
dressed in in
fishnets and on her bed and her boobs
out yeah and then nancy reagan with like
a you know a nuclear looking family and
so someone replied to that with an
excerpt
where it says nancy reagan quote was
renowned in hollywood for performing
oral sex
just say yes nancy
and the days when she was nancy davis
was known to give the best blow job in
town not only in the evening but in
offices that was one of the reasons she
was very popular on the mgm lot it must
have made her very popular with ronnie
as well
wow
dude throw this i didn't realize it
started because of that tweet that's
pretty funny yeah
why are people tweeting that nancy
reagan was the throat code so it's funny
there's a there's a reddit thread about
this like
eight years ago or something like that
and i like just googled it and that
popped up
and all the comments are like wow op was
like
right on the money but like way too
early yeah
yeah it's pretty funny someone tweeted a
picture
it looked like
oh yeah oh man this pete davidson gets
around
damn someone tweeted yeah scroll down
scroll down scroll down that's oh oh no
not that
jesus christ man
i don't know man
i guess it is the bonus
i thought it was gonna be that one it
was an image it looked like a line
for like a like uh like a supreme store
or something there's tons of people in
this line it was like nancy's on the lot
today
just a bunch of extras
yeah so
shout out mark rober can't wait for you
to recreate her neck but i'm just you
know what do you think nancy was good at
like in her day what constituted a good
[ __ ]
i don't know nice and moist do you think
they had like techniques do you think a
good [ __ ] then was different from a
good blow job now
yeah i don't think they were doing like
the guck and the sloppy top i think i
think she probably was maybe that's why
yeah she was yeah she's like
getting after it you've never seen the
way that this is sick
yeah
violent head violent head
gagging on it yeah yeah now we're just
fantasizing about nancy
dude they're gonna make a netflix
documentary like living through nancy
it's gonna be all the guys that ever got
ahead from her that are still alive
don't forget netflix will be hulu
because you know we kind of got in
trouble for the travis scott documentary
so we wanted to move quickly on
something else yeah
a bunch of old guys nancy
blew
my balls apart
that woman was a devil and a banshee
she sucked the soul out of me i watch
people dying numb and
it compares nothing to what she does to
you
[Laughter]
anyway shout out to nancy's neck
classy living you know classy living
yeah
classical abbey yeah was that her name
classic abby classic abby i think yeah
yeah that's so crazy i wonder if her
family knew that ronnie probably did
yeah
you know ronnie was pissed off when he
found out everyone knew yeah
he's going to [ __ ]
different kind of parties and functions
and they're like are you with
oh how's nancy
doing
just say yes now you spoke to her in a
minute yeah what do you mean just say
yes nancy i mean she's like just really
down for whatever
she's always down man
she always down man
what do you mean by that
guy she's hugging guys just a little too
familiar with parties and [ __ ] oh hey
eric
i haven't seen you you know my husband
now ronnie oh yeah yeah me and ronnie
were just talking i was just telling him
man you love to party stop it those days
are over
it's just me and ronnie now
ronnie's just the only guy in the room
like
what do you mean how how do you guys
know each other
oh we're just friends yeah
okay
can you explain
there's nothing to explain bro we're
just you know we were cool back in the
day
she turned ronnie into an incel
very like-minded yeah
you know we've shared some things yeah
let me tell you nancy is a good way of
getting in your head
this woman
mind-blowing
nancy why was everyone at the party like
so why do why they all know you like
that well
i used to ask this is embarrassing i
used to have this nickname and i don't
want to get into this right now but no
you have to tell me dude i'm literally
the president of the united states like
you have to tell me i it's just it's
you're not gonna like it and it's just
it was what is
a long time ago and it's just it's
embarrassing i don't really want are you
cheating on me
no
then what what is it they used to call
me the throat goat
i'm gonna put crack in literally
everyone's [ __ ] neighborhood dude
[Laughter]
i'm putting drugs in literally
everyone's neighborhood i will not be
embarrassed like this
i'm literally gonna [ __ ] kill
everyone oh my god dude and that's
straight from the history books i'm
literally gonna snap
i'm putting drugs in everyone's
neighborhood that's what that's what
ronnie said yeah and why do they only
tell us now i don't know someone was
like digging up like old tweets
i think it was iced tea had a tweet like
it was like shout out to nancy reagan or
something
there's like something vague about nancy
reagan
from how long ago 2017
and people were tweeting like
[Applause]
oh i feel like i can't fully take credit
for that [ __ ] punchline
what no i say i can't fully take credit
for that punch lane zack box made that
joke perks first of it
that's so funny to read that iced tea
tweet in 2017 and be like what yeah why
are you talking about a bad tweet man
we weird tweet dude mid bro delete
delete this he's talking about shout out
nancy reagan what why would you ever
hang out nancy reagan weird random dude
all these people get on iced tea
conservative apologist what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you man
[ __ ] shout out nancy reagan what in
your [ __ ] mind
are you going on about and i see just
like
they're not ready
they're just simply not ready
they just can't they won't be able to
handle it
you